hallo zusammen hallo zusammen ich heiße
lenny und ich bin heute euer lehrer
ich heiße lenny und ich bin heute euer
lehrer heute lernen wir heute lernen wir
den konjunktiv 2 den konjunktiv 2 also
hört gut zu und passt auf also hört gut
zu und passt auf mit dem konjunktiv zwei
beschreiben wir immer einen wunsch eine
fantasie oder etwas irreales mit dem
konjunktiv zwei beschreiben wir immer
einen wunsch eine fantasie oder etwas
irreales mit dem verb sein benutzen wir
wären mit dem verb sein benutzen wir
wäre
wir uns einige beispiele dazu an sehen
wir uns einige beispiele dazu an
ich wäre jetzt gern im urlaub
wenn ich im urlaub wäre wäre ich am
strand
ich wäre gern millionärin
[Musik]
wenn ich millionärin wäre wäre ich in
meinem privatjet
ich wäre gern noch einmal sieben jahre
alt
wenn ich noch einmal sieben jahre alt
wäre wäre ich in der schule
ich wäre gern drei meter groß
wenn ich drei meter groß wäre wäre ich
sehr stark
alles klar alles klar
mit dem werk haben benutzen wir hätte
nun sehen wir einige beispiele mit dem
werk haben
nun sehen wir einige beispiele
mit dem werk haben
ich hätte gern einen hund
ich hätte gerne einen hund
wenn ich einen hund hätte hätte ich viel
spaß
ich hätte gern ein schnelles auto
wenn ich ein schnelles auto hätte hätte
ich oft probleme mit der polizei
ich hätte gern ein großes haus
wenn ich ein großes haus hätte hätte ich
viel platz
wenn ich ein großes haus
hätte hätte ich viel platz
ich hätte gern elf kinder
wenn ich elf kinder hätte hätte ich eine
fußballmannschaft
ich hätte gern viele neue schuhe
wenn ich viele neue schuhe hätte hätte
ich jeden tag andere schuhe
verstanden verstanden
bei den modellen
benutzen wir die konjunktiv zwei formen
und das zweite werk steht im infiniti iv
am satzende
wenn ich doch bloß gitarre spielen
könnte
wenn ich gitarre spielen könnte könnte
ich konzerte geben
wenn ich doch bloß fliegen könnte
wenn ich fliegen könnte könnte ich zum
mond fliegen
wenn ich doch bloß für nichts bezahlen
müsste
wenn ich für nichts bezahlen müsste
müsste ich nicht mehr arbeiten
wüsste ich nicht mehr arbeiten
ich hoffe dass wir das verstanden habt
ich hoffe dass sie das verstanden habt
wenn wir ein anderes werk haben benutzen
wir das hilfswerk würden und dass andere
verb steht im infiniti iv am satzende
wenn wir ein anderes werk haben benutzen
wir das werk würden und dass andere verb
steht im infiniti iv am satzende was
würde passieren wenn du jemanden
ausrauben würdest was würde passieren
wenn du jemanden ausrauben würdest
wenn ich jemanden ausrauben
würde würde mich die polizei verhaften
wenn ich jemanden ausrauben würde würde
mich die polizei verhaften
was würdest du machen wenn ein
außerirdischer in deinem garten landen
würde
was würdest du machen wenn ein
außerirdischer in deinem garten landen
würde
wenn ein außerirdischer in meinem garten
landen würde würde ich mit ihm einen
kaffee trinken
wenn ein außerirdischer in meinem garten
landen würde würde ich mit ihm einen
kaffee trinken
[Musik]
was würdest du machen wenn dich ein
zombie angreifen würde
wenn mich ein zombie angreifen würde
würde ich schnell weglaufen
was sind wir zusammen fassen wir
zusammen
das verb sein wird zu
das verb sein wird zu wäre wäre das werk
haben wird zu
das verb haben wert zu hätte hätte das
werk müssen
wer zu das verb müssen wert zu müsste
müsste das verb dürfen wird zu
das verb dürfen wir zu dürfte dürfte das
wäre
wer zu das verb sollen wert zu sollte
das vermögen wert zu
das vermögen wert zu möchte möchte das
verb können wird zu
das verb können wert zu könnte könnte
bei allen anderen werben würden und
infiniti iv bei allen anderen werben
würden und infiniti jetzt sehen wir
einige beispiele mit gemischten wenn
setzen
jetzt sehen wir einige beispiele mit
gemischten wenn setzen
was würdest du machen wenn du reich
wirst
was würdest du machen wenn du reich wärs
wenn ich reich wäre würde ich mir ein
brot kaufen
boot kaufen
was würde passieren wenn du fußball
spielen könntest
was
wenn du fußball spielen könntest
wenn ich fußball spielen könnte wäre ich
berühmt
was würdest du machen wenn du ein pferd
hättest
wenn ich ein pferd hätte würde ich oft
reiten
[Musik]
wenn ich ein pferd hätte würde ich oft
reiten
was würde passieren
wenn du super woman wärs
was würde passieren wenn du super woman
wärs
wenn ich super wurmen wäre könnte ich
fliegen
[Musik]
was würde passieren
wenn dein großvater sterben würde
was wird
ihren wenn dein großvater stärken würde
denn mein großvater sterben würde wäre
ich traurig
wenn mein großvater sterben würde wäre
was würdest du machen wenn du am meer
leben würdest
was
denn wenn du am meer leben würdest
wenn ich am meer leben würde könnte ich
surfen
[Musik]
wenn ich am meer leben würde könnte ich
surfen
folgt und
aktiviert die glocke
schreibt einen
h
[Musik]